right now i'm sure he's laughing in
heaven
because i'm about to praise him in
public for his accomplishments on one of
the most public stages
i can see him now arms folded with a
huge grin
saying isn't this some sh
the late kobe bryant was inducted into
the basketball hall of fame over the
weekend
and his widow vanessa couldn't help but
get emotional during her touching speech
i wish my husband was here to accept
this incredible award
he and gigi deserve to be here to
witness this
gigi would be so proud to watch her
daddy get enshrined into the basketball
hall of fame
i know kobe is really looking forward to
being here
he uh he asked the hall of fame to
specifically add
a sixth ticket for capri he was so happy
vanessa clad in a lakers purple dolce
gabbana gown
thanked kobe's family and the many
others who have lent their support over
the years
she said her late husband would have had
a long list of people to thank for
helping him reach hall of fame status
including those who doubted him and
worked against him quote
he would thank all of them for
motivating him to be here
after all he proved you wrong kobe had
many accomplishments
but his most cherished accomplishment
was being the very best girl dad
the proud mom went on to praise kobe for
his many achievements
on and off the court but said his
favorite was being a dad to their four
daughters
natalia gianna bianca and capri
thank you for working so tirelessly to
provide for us and for giving us the
most amazing life together
thank you for loving me enough to last
lifetimes
in every lifetime i choose you to our
girls
natalia and gianna thank you for
sacrificing so much time away from daddy
so that he could focus on being the best
at everything he set his mind to do
bianca and capri i'm so happy you're
here to see this tonight
daddy was incredible vanessa ended her
speech with a little humor
i'm glad you bet on yourself you
overachiever
and a lot of love i love you forever and
always
kobe bean bryant
vanessa's speech was given a standing
ovation and
tons of praise on social media she even
got a special shout out from her best
friend
lala anthony who attended the event with
her and called
her the goat who just delivered
the greatest speech of all time would
you guys like to see her
drumroll
she's epic i tell her every day she's
the strongest woman i know
and um i'm really really proud of just
how she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know
as much as i can for her as a friend
she's just an amazing and amazing
human being just just amazing the
special family moments took place
all weekend starting on friday at the
tip-off celebration
and awards gala where vanessa and kobe's
oldest daughter 18 year old natalia was
presented with the late icons hall of
fame
jacket and ring
vanessa also shared snaps from her
family's tour of kobe's hall of fame
exhibit
here's four-year-old bianca posing in
front of her dad's iconic jerseys
and here's nearly two-year-old capri
smiling big
in front of a giant photo of her
legendary dad
our responsibility is to always inspire
and try to take some of the life lessons
that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start
their journey with a leg up
[Music]
you